OK. As adults, it's pretty rare to have a moment where you're talking with somebody in your own country, in your own hometown, in your own language, and you have no idea what is actually happening, where things become confusing, and not in that oh, what did he mean by that sort of way, but in an I Love Lucy , how did I get myself into this situation kind of confusion. Like for example, Amy, who was back home in Indiana on a break from college. And she was accompanying her brother's high school class on a trip to this health and science museum they have in South Bend called the HealthWorks! Kids Museum. And just to give you a sense of who the characters are in this story, Amy's brother is autistic. And he is moderately mentally retarded.
好的。作为成年人，在一个属于你自己的国家、你自己的家乡、用你自己的母语与人交谈，却完全不知道发生了什么，感到困惑，这其实是很少见的。那种困惑不是“哦，他这话是什么意思”的那种，而是一种类似《我爱露西》里那种“我是怎么陷入这种境地的”困惑。比如艾米，她当时从大学放假回家，回到印第安纳州。她陪她弟弟的高中班级去南本德的一家健康与科学博物馆参观，博物馆叫HealthWorks!儿童博物馆。为了让你了解这个故事里的人物，艾米的弟弟患有自闭症，而且有中度的智力障碍。
If you had to picture Ben, I would say picture this really handsome, star athlete looking guy who sort of has an age of maybe five to eight years old, and loves dinosaurs.
如果你要想象本的样子，我会说想象一个非常英俊、看起来像明星运动员的家伙，但他大概只有五到八岁的智力，而且非常喜欢恐龙。
As for Amy, aside from the fact that she's very close to her brother, you can get a good sense of who she is by the conversation that she had with Ben's teacher on the bus with all the developmentally-disabled kids, driving to this museum. Amy was talking to the teacher about her schoolwork, which, frankly, seems very, very hard. Amy was majoring in physics and studying in Germany.
至于艾米，除了她和弟弟关系非常亲密之外，你可以通过她在巴士上与本的老师的谈话来了解她。巴士上坐满了发育迟缓的孩子，正前往那个博物馆。艾米在和老师谈论她的学业，说实话，她的学业看起来非常非常难。艾米主修物理，正在德国留学。
In Germany, not only were the classes in German, but we were also using all of these graduate textbooks. But she was really nice. And she just listened to me the whole way over.
在德国，不仅课程是德语授课，而且我们还使用所有这些研究生教材。但她人非常好。她在我去的那一路都在听我说话。
So they get to the museum. And after some videos and some science experiments where they blow things up, it was time to walk around the exhibits.
于是他们到达了博物馆。在看了一些视频和一些会引起爆炸的科学实验后，是时候去参观展览了。
So during all of this, one of the things that they had been really pushing, they had these new computers that were installed. They were computers designed to walk kids through making a really neat identification card. And they were all really excited about this. I think they must have just gone live the day before we came. Because they were all just, make sure you use our ID computers. We're so excited about this. And you get to print out your ID and pick it up at the front desk. And so when we walk out onto the actual museum part, my brother and I walk around. And he shows me some of his favorite exhibits. And this staff member comes up to me. And he says, have you made your ID yet?
所以在这一切过程中，他们一直在大力推广一件事，他们安装了新的电脑。这些电脑旨在引导孩子们制作一张非常精致的身份证。他们对此都感到非常兴奋。我想这些电脑一定是在我们去的前一天才投入使用的。因为他们都在说，一定要用我们的身份证电脑。我们对此非常兴奋。你可以打印出你的身份证，然后在前台领取。当我们走到博物馆的实际展览区时，我和弟弟四处走动。他向我展示了他最喜欢的一些展品。一位工作人员走过来对我说，你做过身份证了吗？
Now, for a second it seems a little weird that he would ask one of the adults to make an ID card. But Amy figured it's new. They're excited for everybody to try this thing, kids and adults. So her brother ambles off, and she sits down and starts answering the questions on her computer screen. And the guy doesn't go away. He keeps finding ways to help her.
现在，他问一个成年人去做身份证，这看起来有点奇怪。但艾米想，这是新的东西。他们对每个人——孩子和成年人——都尝试这个感到兴奋。于是她弟弟慢悠悠地走开了，她坐下来开始回答电脑屏幕上的问题。那个家伙没有走开。他不断地找机会帮助她。
Then it occurred to me, oh, well maybe he's hitting on me a little bit.
然后我突然想到，哦，也许他是在跟我搭讪。
Which would make sense. But the help that he's giving her keeps getting stranger and stranger. He's giving her instructions for things that no fully-functioning adult would ever need instructions for. And Amy wonders, does he think that she is one of the developmentally-disabled kids who are wandering all over the museum? But at the same time, Amy thought that it was completely obviously that she wasn't-- the way she moved, the way she expressed herself. And the guy's manner, his tone of voice, was unmistakable. He talked to her like a peer.
这倒是说得通。但他给她的帮助却越来越奇怪。他给她的说明是任何功能正常的成年人根本不需要的。艾米心想，他是不是以为她是那些在博物馆里到处游荡的发育迟缓的孩子之一？但同时，艾米认为她显然不是——她移动的方式、她表达自己的方式。而且那个家伙的态度、语气都无可置疑。他像对待同龄人一样和她说话。
I almost wonder if maybe that was why I was almost paralyzed with confusion. It's really rare to meet people who don't use some kind of special voice with the mentally disabled, this slightly higher pitched, slightly I know you're a special person kind of voice. So it was so strange.
我甚至怀疑这是否就是我几乎被困惑感瘫痪的原因。很少遇到不对比智障人士使用某种特殊语调的人，那种稍微尖细一点的、那种“我知道你是特殊人士”的语调。所以这太奇怪了。
And then, luckily, the very next question that comes up on the computer screen is one that Amy realizes can resolve all of this confusion, once and for all, definitively, for the both of them.
然后，幸运的是，电脑屏幕上出现的下一个问题让艾米意识到，这个问题可以一劳永逸地解决他们两人的困惑。
So the question is, type in your age. OK, so I'm 21 years old at the time. So I'm thinking, I can type in 21. And he'll realize that I can't be a student. And we can just both pretend like we understood what was going on this whole time. So I type in 21. And he looks at me, and he looks at the age. And he says, oh Amy, you know, if your age is a number that ends in teen, then that number starts with a one.
问题是，输入你的年龄。好吧，当时我21岁。所以我心想，我可以输入21。他就会意识到我不可能是一个学生。我们可以假装我们一直都知道发生了什么。所以我输入了21。他看着我，又看了看年龄。他说，哦，艾米，你知道，如果你的年龄是一个以“teen”结尾的数字，那么那个数字是以“1”开头的。
So he just assumes you've typed wrong.
所以他只是假设你输错了。
Yeah. But I haven't. So at that point, I decide that instead of saying, OK, actually I am 21, and then letting that fold out however it would have, I erase what I typed, and I type in 18.
是的。但我没输错。所以在那一刻，我决定不直接说“好吧，其实我21岁了”，然后任由事态发展，而是删掉了我输入的数字，输入了18。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know. How many more questions could there possibly be? I've already told them everything about myself, how much I weigh. And I thought, well, this is just going to be a couple more questions, and then it'll take a photo of me, and then I'll be done. And then he'll never have to know.
我不知道。还能有多少个问题呢？我已经告诉他们关于我的一切了，我的体重是多少。我想，好吧，这大概再过几个问题就结束了，然后拍张照，我就完成了。然后他就永远不会知道真相了。
He's a stranger. You're in a museum. This will be over in, like, a minute. You can walk away. Who cares?
他是个陌生人。你在博物馆。这一切一分钟就结束了。你可以走开。谁在乎呢？
Exactly. I felt like it was the lesser of two evils at that point.
没错。我觉得那是两害相权取其轻。
But she is not near the end of the questionnaire. Far from it. It continues for pages and pages. Then there's a set of paragraph-length questions which require actual concentration.
但她离调查问卷结束还远得很。远不止如此。接着还有几页段落长度的问题，需要真正的集中注意力。
And while fast as I can, I'm skimming these questions, trying to get through these, he starts reading them to me out loud word for word. And I'm sort of melting into my chair. And I'm thinking, this is too much. This is way too much of a deception. I have to somehow stop him.
当我在飞快地浏览这些问题，试图做完它们时，他开始逐字逐句地大声读给我听。我感觉自己都要融化在椅子里了。我想，这太过分了。这骗局搞得太大了。我必须想办法阻止他。
So I did. I said, oh, I can read. And he looks at me. He puts his hand on my back. And he says, your parents must be so proud of you. So as you might imagine, I'm working really hard to skim through these questions as quickly-- I'm a blur of activity. I'm just trying to get through these questions so I can get out of this room and escape. And as I'm working through these questions as fast as I can, I see my brother's teacher walking towards me. And she says, hey Amy, how's it going?
所以我阻止了他。我说，哦，我会识字。他看着我。他把手放在我的背上。他说，你的父母一定为你感到骄傲。你可以想象，我正在非常努力地尽快浏览这些问题——我动作飞快。我只是想做完这些问题，好让我离开这个房间逃走。就在我以最快速度做题时，我看到我弟弟的老师向我走来。她说，嘿，艾米，进展如何？
And you're thinking, like, oh my God. What's going to happen?
你当时肯定想，天哪。会发生什么？
Oh, oh, yeah. And then it happens. He points to me and he says-- again, voice full of admiration and pride-- and he says, Amy was just telling me that she can read.
哦，噢，是的。然后事情发生了。他指着我说——声音里再次充满了钦佩和自豪——他说，艾米刚才告诉我她会识字。
And how does the teacher take this news?
老师听到这个消息后是什么反应？
Oh my gosh. So this teacher, who I'd been complaining to about these graduate-level classes in German, she looks at him. And she says, of course Amy can read.
天哪。所以这位我一直在抱怨那些德国研究生课程难度的老师，她看着他。她说，艾米当然会识字。
And then the truth pours out. There begins a flurrying of apologizing on all sides, Amy apologizing to the guy, the guy apologizing to Amy. Both of them, she says, clutching their own hearts as they do this. It turns out he's so careful not to talk down to developmentally-disabled students because he himself had a learning disability. And so she had misread what he was doing, and why he spoke the way he did. And he misread who she really was. And in this case, they both discovered the truth. But just as often, people meet and walk away and never straighten this stuff out. They assume, they get it all wrong. And that is the subject of today's program.
然后真相大白了。各方开始了一阵道歉，艾米向那个家伙道歉，那个家伙向艾米道歉。她说，两人在道歉时都紧紧抓着自己的心口。原来他之所以特别小心不去居高临下地对待发育迟缓的学生，是因为他自己就有学习障碍。所以她误读了他所做的事情以及他说话的原因。而他误读了她究竟是谁。在这个案例中，他们都发现了真相。但通常人们相遇后走开，却永远不会澄清这些事情。他们做出假设，结果全搞错了。而这就是今天节目的主题。
From Chicago Public Radio, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, I've Got you Pegged, stories of people assuming all kinds of things about other people, usually in error. Our show today, in four acts. And it is quite a lineup-- Richard Price, Chuck Klosterman, Shalom Auslander, and Nancy Updike. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥公共电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“我把你定型了”，讲述人们对他人做出各种假设，通常是错误的。我们今天的节目分为四幕。阵容相当强大——理查德·普莱斯、查克·克洛斯特曼、沙洛姆·奥斯兰德和南希·厄普代克。请继续收听。
Act One, The Fat Blue Line. We begin today with a story about something that happens all the time, in all kinds of places, something that is so common that it's not even big enough to make it on the local news. Richard Price tells the story. A novelist and screenwriter, he often writes about cops and crime. He wrote Clockers. He wrote Sea of Love. He wrote for the TV show The Wire. His most recent novel is Lush Life. He told this story onstage at the Moth in New York. He describes it as a tale taken from real life and dramatized.
第一幕，肥胖蓝线。我们以一个每天在各种地方都会发生的故事开始今天的节目，这太常见了，甚至不够登上当地新闻。理查德·普莱斯讲述了这个故事。作为一名小说家和编剧，他经常撰写关于警察和犯罪的故事。他写过《时钟制造者》。他写过《海之恋》。他为电视剧《火线》写过剧本。他最近的小说是《郁郁葱葱的生活》。他在纽约的 Moth 舞台上讲述了这个故事。他将其描述为一个取材于真实生活并戏剧化的故事。
In the last novel I wrote, I spent a lot of time on the Lower East Side. And as is my wont, I wound up in the back of police cars a lot. And Lower East Side is a very low-crime area right now. It used to be the worst. But Giuliani and real estate pressure took care of that. And now they basically have nothing to do down there, in terms of crime. So what they do is they sit in fake taxis. Four beefy white guys sit in a fake taxi by the side of Williamsburg Bridge. And they eyeball what's coming over from Brooklyn. And if the car looks like a $200 [BLEEP] box, or somebody's got an afro or a ponytail, they pull in behind the car, and they wait to see if the guy's going to go all polite in his driving, like put on lane-change signals. Then they know he's dirty.
在我写的上一本小说里，我在下东区待了很长时间。按照我的习惯，我经常坐在警车后座。下东区现在是一个犯罪率很低的地区。过去这里是最糟糕的地方。但朱利安尼和房地产压力解决了这个问题。现在他们在那里基本上没什么事可做，就犯罪而言。所以他们做的是坐在假出租车里。四个壮实的白人坐在威廉斯堡大桥旁的一辆假出租车里。他们审视着从布鲁克林过来的人。如果那辆车看起来像个200美元的破烂货，或者有人留着非洲头或马尾辫，他们就跟在车后面，看看那家伙开车是否表现得彬彬有礼，比如打变道信号。如果打了，他们就知道他有问题。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And so worst comes to worse, it's fishing, really. It's a big fishing hole, Delancey Street. And so I spent all night in this bogus taxi with about 850 pounds of white beef.
所以最坏的情况，这其实就是钓鱼。迪兰西街就是一个巨大的鱼塘。所以我整晚都和大约850磅的白人壮汉坐在那辆冒牌出租车里。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And it's the end of the night. They've made their collars. And there are two cops up front. And I'm sitting in the back. And when I ride with these guys, I don't really comment about what they do. I don't engage them in any kind of debates. It's like I'm there to bear witness, and then see what I can do with it in my work. Anyway, they're riding up Essex Street. It's kind of Miller time. And as they're going up, they pass a black guy, about 30 years old with dreads on a bicycle. And on the crossbars, he's got a white kid, about nine, 10 years old. And the black guy and the white kid, they're kind of chatting. The kid's looking up at the guy. They look like they're sort of familiar with each other.
快到深夜了。他们已经抓到人了。前座坐着两个警察。我坐在后座。当我和这些人一起出勤时，我并不真的评论他们的行为。我不参与任何形式的辩论。我就像是在那里见证，然后看看能在我的作品中利用这些素材做些什么。总之，他们正开着车沿艾塞克斯街行驶。差不多到了休息时间。当他们向上行驶时，他们经过一个30岁左右、留着脏辫的黑人，他骑着自行车。横梁上坐着一个白人小孩，大约9、10岁。那个黑人和白人小孩正聊着天。孩子抬头看着那个人。他们看起来彼此很熟。
And the cops drive by. And they're dead silent. And after about a block, one guy says to the other, he says, hey, big guy, does that look fishy to you? He says, it's [BLEEP] midnight. What's going on here? He said, well, what do you want to do, big guy? So I'll tell you, big guy. All right, make the light. Pull over, let's see what's what. So they pull over. The bike's coming up Essex.
警察开车经过。他们死一般寂静。过了一个街区后，一个人对另一个人说，他说，嘿，大个子，那看起来可疑吗？他说，现在是半夜。这怎么回事？他说，好吧，你想做什么，大个子？我来告诉你，大个子。好吧，在那边停车，看看是怎么回事。于是他们靠边停车。自行车正沿着艾塞克斯街过来。
One of the cops steps in the road, puts his hand out, and says, hey, how are you doing? Get off the bike, please. And the black guy gets off the bike. And he goes, hey officers, like it's an unexpected treat. You know, hi, what's up?
其中一个警察走到路上，伸出手说，嘿，你好吗？请下车。那个黑人下了车。他说，嘿，警官，就好像这是个意外的惊喜。你知道，嗨，怎么了？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he says, did you ever hear of helmets? Oh yeah, gee, I'm really sorry. At which point the other cop says to the little white kid, he says, hey big guy, what's your name? He goes, um, Noah Rosenberg? Like he's not sure. And he says, hey Noah, come here, buddy. Come on over here. And he separates the two. And I'm sort of hopping in between the two conversations at this point.
他说，你听说过头盔吗？哦，天哪，我真的很抱歉。这时另一个警察对那个小白人小孩说，他说，嘿，大个子，你叫什么名字？他回答，呃，诺亚·罗森伯格？好像他不确定。他说，嘿，诺亚，过来，伙伴。来这边。他把两人分开了。此时我在两个对话之间跳来跳去。
And the black guy tries to follow the white kid. And the other cop puts his hand on his chest. And he says, no, you stay over here. Let me see some ID. He says, what? He says, some ID. He says, don't look at him. Look at me. He says, no, I was just picking him up from a play date. Did I ask you that? No, no, you don't understand. I work the bar at Schiller's. Again, did I ask you that? Well, no. He says, why are you trying to divert me? He says, I'm not. Go down the same road as me. He goes, OK, OK.
那个黑人试图跟着白人小孩。另一个警察把手按在他的胸口。他说，不，你待在这儿。让我看看证件。他说，什么？他说，证件。他说，别看他。看我。他说，不，我只是刚从玩伴家接他回来。我问你那个了吗？没有，不，你不明白。我在席勒酒吧工作。再说一遍，我问你那个了吗？嗯，没有。他说，你为什么要转移话题？他说，我没有。走跟我一样的路。他说，好吧，好吧。
And he gives him the ID, at which point, he sort of waves to the kid. And he goes, oh, what did I just say to you? He says, no, no, I'm really sorry. It's Noah. He's kind of wound a little tight. And he says, oh, really? Have a seat. He points to the curb, and he makes the guy sit on the curb with his feet in the gutter.
他交出了证件，这时他向孩子招了招手。他说，哦，我刚才对你说什么了？他说，不，不，我真的很抱歉。是诺亚。他有点紧张。他说，哦，真的吗？坐下。他指着路边，让那个人坐在路边，双脚放在阴沟里。
And he says, so where are you going? He says, well, I had the late shift. And he says, it's kind of late to be driving around with a kid on a bike, isn't it? At which point I leave those two. And I go over to Noah and the other cop. And he says, so your name's Noah, huh? And the kid says, yes, and for the millionth time, I don't have an ark.
他说，那你们要去哪儿？他说，好吧，我刚上完晚班。他说，大半夜带着孩子骑车，挺晚的吧？就在这时我离开了那两人。我走到诺亚和另一个警察那边。他说，所以你叫诺亚，是吗？孩子说，是的，而且已经说了几百万遍了，我没有诺亚方舟。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the cop says, boy, you must get that a lot. And the kid says, oh my God, you have no idea. And he says, so Noah, how old are you? He says, well next week I'll be a decade old. And he said, well that's great, great. And where do you live? He says, 333 Avenue B. And he says, and you go to school around here? He says yes, I go to the Earth School. And he says, oh, cool. And who do you live with? He says, I live with my mom.
警察说，孩子，你一定经常被这么问。孩子说，天哪，你根本不知道。他说，那么诺亚，你多大了？他说，下周我就十岁了。他说，那太好了，太好了。你住哪儿？他说，B大道333号。他说，你在这附近上学吗？他说，是的，我去地球学校。他说，哦，酷。你和谁住在一起？他说，我和妈妈住。
And he goes, and who's that over there? He says, well, I don't know who your friend is, but my friend is Cleve. And he says, oh, do you know what Cleve's last name is? He says, yeah, Carter. Cleve Carter. Sometimes I call him Coca-Cola. Sometimes I call him Carbon Copy.
他说，那边那个人是谁？他说，好吧，我不知道你的朋友是谁，但我的朋友是克里夫。他说，哦，你知道克里夫的姓吗？他说，知道，卡特。克里夫·卡特。有时我叫他可口可乐。有时我叫他碳素复印件。
He says, oh, do you know him for long? He says, well, yeah, like, one, one and a quarter years. He's kind of like my godfather, since my other godfather died. Oh, and what do you guys do? Well, he was taking me home from a play date to my mom's. He says, so he knows your mom? And he says, well, yeah. He and my mom are kind of like friends. And he says, kind of like? He says, well, they have, like, sleep-over dates.
他说，哦，你们认识很久了吗？他说，嗯，是的，大概一年，一年零三个月。他就像我的教父，因为我的前任教父去世了。哦，你们平时做什么？嗯，他带我从玩伴家回我妈妈那儿。他说，所以他认识你妈妈？他说，嗯，是的。他和我的妈妈就像是朋友。他说，就像是？他说，嗯，他们会一起过夜什么的。
And he says, so your mom knows that you're with him now? He says, well, my mom sent him to pick me up. My dad lives in Woodstock. He says, OK.
他说，所以你妈妈知道你现在和他在一起吗？他说，嗯，我妈妈派他来接我的。我爸爸住在伍德斯托克。他说，好吧。
At which point, I'm going, OK, let's see what's happening with Cleve. I walk over there. Cleve's sitting on the curb, and he's got his feet out there. And he's trying to make it look like it's natural. So he was massaging his deep thigh muscles, like he's limbering up for the marathon or something. This is humiliating. And he's kind of smiling, because you can't win. You've got to play through. And he's sitting there. And the other cop is hitting his driver's license with a Maglite, one of those big, powerful flashlights. And he goes, so Cleveland, I see you're from Ohio.
就在这时，我在想，好吧，看看克里夫那边发生了什么。我走过去。克里夫坐在路边，双脚伸在那里。他正试图表现得自然一点。所以他在按摩大腿肌肉，好像在为马拉松热身什么的。这太丢人了。他还在笑，因为你赢不了。你必须配合演下去。他坐在那里。另一个警察正用 Maglite（那种强力手电筒）敲打他的驾照。他说，所以克利夫兰，我看到你是俄亥俄州的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he says, yeah. He says, Cleveland from Ohio. He says, well, actually, it's from Oxford. And the guy goes, oh, Miami College. And he goes, yeah, that's where I went. And the cop goes, oh, Wally Szczerbiak, who is this big basketball player. And he goes, well, yeah, Wally was a little before my time. He said, oh, did you play ball for them too? He said, well, not basketball. I played soccer. He said, oh, that amazing, because I teach soccer. I coach soccer out on the Island, you know, the kids' league. And he says, you know it's amazing. I keep waiting for that sport to blow up, but I don't think it's-- and Cleveland's going, yeah, yeah, that's amazing. He's sitting, you know.
他说，是的。他说，克利夫兰，来自俄亥俄州。他说，好吧，其实，我是来自牛津。那人说，哦，迈阿密学院。他说，是的，那是我的母校。警察说，哦，沃利·塞比亚克，那个大篮球运动员。他说，嗯，是的，沃利在我之前。他说，哦，你也为他们打球吗？他说，嗯，不是篮球。我踢足球。他说，哦，那太棒了，因为我教足球。我在岛上当足球教练，你知道，儿童联盟。他说，你知道这很神奇。我一直等着这项运动火起来，但我不觉得……克利夫兰说，是的，是的，那太棒了。他坐在那儿。
At which point, a Mustang comes by with two black guys in it, up Essex. And the guy in the shotgun seat looks out the windows and he sees Cleveland sitting on the curb. And he starts yelling out, homeboy to base, homeboy to base, we've got a black man down. I repeat, a black man down. And he's laughing his ass off. And the Mustang floors it. And Cleveland's kind of squinting. And he's just kind of looking the other way. He's just mortified.
就在这时，一辆野马跑车开过，车里有两个黑人，沿艾塞克斯街向上行驶。坐在副驾驶的人从窗外看去，看到了坐在路边的克利夫兰。他开始大喊，homie（兄弟）向基地报告，homie向基地报告，我们有一个黑人倒下了。我重复一遍，一个黑人倒下了。他笑得前仰后合。野马车全速开走了。克利夫兰眯着眼。他只是看向别处。他简直丢脸死了。
Then hopping back to the other cop with the kid, he says, so Noah, does Cleveland live with you? He goes, no, Cleveland lives at 444 Avenue D. We live at 332 Avenue B. He says, well you ever been over to his house? He says, only about a million times. And he says, mostly with your mom, I guess. He says, and by myself. He said, oh really? What do you do there? He says, well, sometimes we walk his dog. It's a Rhodesian Ridgeback named Mars. And one time, he tried teaching me how to make scrambled eggs, but I don't really like his oven because you light the pilot match and it goes foo. And it scares me. And he says, one time my mom had to go to court in Woodstock. And I stayed with Cleveland for three days. And he said, in court, huh? He said, yeah. Three days? He said, yeah. He said, but mostly I'd say 82 and 1/2% of the time, we watch television. You and Cleveland? He said, yeah, me and Cleve.
然后回到带孩子的那个警察那里，他说，所以诺亚，克利夫住你家吗？他说，不，克利夫住在D大道444号。我们住在B大道332号。他说，你有没有去过他家？他说，大概有几百万次吧。他说，大多是和你妈妈一起吧，我猜。他说，还有我自己去。他说，哦，真的吗？你们做什么？他说，嗯，有时我们遛他的狗。是一只叫马斯的罗得西亚脊背犬。有一次，他试着教我怎么做炒蛋，但我不喜欢他的烤箱，因为你点燃引火火柴，它会“呼”地一声响。这吓到我了。他说，有一次我妈妈不得不去伍德斯托克出庭。我和克利夫呆了三天。他说，出庭，是吗？他说，是啊。三天？他说，是啊。他说，但我会说82.5%的时间，我们都在看电视。你和克利夫？他说，是的，我和克利夫。
And and the cop said to him, do you ever do anything else with him? And he goes, what? What do you mean? And he goes, do you do anything else with him? And all of a sudden, the kid's eyes get really big and kind of wet, like steel. And the kid starts breathing kind of heavy. And the cop starts shaking a little bit. And the cop says to him, hey Noah, look at this. And he pulls his jacket back. And he shows him this detective shield on his belt. He says, you know what that is? He says, yeah, it's a police badge. He says, you know what this means? He says, what? He says, that means you can tell me anything you want and you'll be perfectly safe. Do you understand that?
警察问他，你和他还做过其他事情吗？他回答，什么？你什么意思？他说，你和他还做过其他事情吗？突然之间，孩子的眼睛变得又大又湿，像钢铁一样。孩子开始呼吸变得沉重。警察开始有点发抖。警察对他说，嘿，诺亚，看这个。他向后拉开外套。他给他看腰带上的侦探证章。他说，你知道那是什么吗？他说，知道，那是警察徽章。他说，你知道这意味着什么吗？他说，什么？他说，这意味着你可以告诉我任何你想说的话，你会非常安全。你明白吗？
And the kid looks at him and he goes, oh my God, are you going to arrest him? And the cop, his heart's pumping Kool-Aid, and he starts moving over. And he says, why? And the kid goes, if you [BLEEP] [BLEEP] arrest him again one more time just because he's black and I'm not, I'm going to kill myself. You came into my apartment and dragged him out because the crazy lady next door said he was a rapist. You put him in handcuffs when he came to pick me up at school. You pulled him away from me at the street fair and made me wait for my mom. He said, I swear to God, I'm going to lose my mind.
孩子看着他，然后说，天哪，你要逮捕他吗？警察心跳加速，他开始走过去。他说，为什么？孩子说，如果你再敢因为他是个黑人而我不是，就把他逮捕，我就去自杀。你们闯进我的公寓把他拖走，就因为隔壁的疯女人说他是强奸犯。当他来学校接我时，你们给他戴上了手铐。在街头集市上你们把他从我身边拉走，让我等妈妈。他说，我发誓，我要疯了。
And the cops go whoa, easy, easy, easy. At which point, both cops are looking at each other, like, well, what's going on? And all of a sudden, Cleveland sees the kid's losing it. And he goes, hey, Noah, buddy. And the cop goes, what did I just say to you? Stop talking to the kid.
警察说，喔，冷静，冷静。这时，两个警察互相看着，心想，到底发生了什么？突然，克利夫兰看到孩子要崩溃了。他说，嘿，诺亚，伙计。警察说，我刚才说什么了？别跟孩子说话。
And at which point, Cleveland says, officer, you want to put this to rest? I'll tell you what. I'm reaching for my cell phone in here. He says, why don't you call the kid's mom and just see what's going on? He says, I'll call the kid's mom. He says, what's her name? He goes, Idina. And he calls across to the other cop, get the kid's mother's name. And the kid, through sobs, is going, Idina. And Cleveland gives the cop the mother's number. The cop calls, and he says, hey, how are you doing? This is Sergeant Daley from the seventh precinct. Who am I speaking to? And she goes, oh my God. Idina Rosenberg. What happened? He goes, not a thing happened. I just need to know, do you know where your son is right now? And which point she freaks. And she goes, where is he? What happened? He's supposed to be with Cleveland. He's supposed to be taking him home from a play date. What happened? What happened? What happened? Well, no, no, no, he's fine, OK? At which point, the kid goes, my mom says that if I get any more nervous, I'm going to have to live with my father in Woodstock, you [BLEEP].
就在这时，克利夫兰说，警官，你想平息这件事吗？告诉你。我正在拿这儿的手机。他说，你为什么不给孩子的妈妈打电话看看是怎么回事？他说，我给孩子的妈妈打电话。他说，她叫什么名字？他说，艾迪娜。他对着另一个警察喊，去查孩子母亲的名字。孩子在抽泣声中说，艾迪娜。克利夫兰把母亲的电话号码给了警察。警察打了过去，他说，嘿，你好吗？我是第七分局的戴利警官。我是谁在说话？她回答，天哪。艾迪娜·罗森伯格。发生了什么？他说，什么都没发生。我只是需要知道，你知道你儿子现在在哪里吗？就在那时她慌了。她说，他在哪儿？发生了什么？他应该和克利夫在一起。他应该带他从玩伴家回家。发生了什么？发生了什么？发生了什么？好吧，不，不，不，他很好，好吗？就在这时，孩子说，我妈妈说如果我再紧张一点，我就得去伍德斯托克和我爸爸住了，你这个混蛋。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the cop's going, no, no, no. The kid's great. The kid's fine. The only thing is that they were riding without helmets. And it's a serious safety violation. And she's going, oh my God. Oh, Jesus. He says, no, no, no. OK, don't worry about it. Don't worry. All right, good night. Have a good night. And he hangs up. At which point they bring Cleveland and Noah together again. And they give them this half-assed lecture on bicycle safety. And he says, you know, I'm supposed to write you up. But I'm going to give you a pass this time.
警察说，不，不，不。孩子很好。孩子没问题。唯一的问题是他们骑车没戴头盔。这属于严重的违规行为。她说，天哪。哦，上帝啊。他说，不，不，不。好吧，别担心。别担心。好吧，晚安。祝你有个愉快的夜晚。他挂了电话。这时他们把克利夫兰和诺亚带到一起。他们给他们上了一堂半吊子的自行车安全课。他说，你知道，我本该给你开罚单的。但我这次放过你们。
And Cleveland's still kind of smiling, but the smile doesn't go past here. It never reaches his eyes. And he gets back on the bike. And the kid gets on the handlebars. And the kid's going through that post-crying jag, shudder withdrawal. And Cleveland's trying to talk him down as he pushes off. And they go disappear up Essex.
克利夫兰还在笑，但笑容没有到达这里。它从未到达他的眼睛。他重新骑上自行车。孩子坐在车把上。孩子正在经历哭泣后的那种抽搐感。克利夫兰在推车前行时试图安慰他。他们消失在艾塞克斯街上。
And we get back in the police car. And I'm sitting in the back. I'm not saying a [BLEEP] thing. And they go in dead silence for about two blocks. And one cop finally says to the other, he says, you know something big guy? And the other guy says, what's that, big guy? He says, it still feels fishy to me. And the other cop says, hey, we gave it a shot, man. That's all we can do. Thank you.
我们回到了警车里。我坐在后座。我什么混蛋话也没说。他们死一般沉默地开了两个街区。一个警察终于对另一个人说，他说，你知道吗，大个子？另一个人说，什么事，大个子？他说，这对我来说还是感觉很可疑。另一个警察说，嘿，伙计，我们试过了。这就是我们能做的一切。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Richard Price. He's currently adapting his novel, Lush Life, for the movies. He was recorded at the Moth, which has a free podcast and a website with all kinds of stories like the one you just heard. They are at themoth.org.
理查德·普莱斯。他目前正在将他的小说《郁郁葱葱的生活》改编成电影。他是在 Moth 录制的，Moth 有免费的播客和网站，上面有各种各样的故事，就像你刚才听到的那个。他们的网址是 themoth.org。
We all hate stereotypes. Stereotypes are killing us, and they are killing our children. And they are putting LSD into the water supply.
我们都讨厌刻板印象。刻板印象正在杀死我们，也在杀死我们的孩子。它们正在把 LSD 放入供水系统。
That's writer Chuck Klosterman, and this is Act Two of our show.
那是作家查克·克洛斯特曼，这是我们节目的第二幕。
Stereotypes are like rogue elephants with AIDS that have been set on fire by terrorists, except worse. We all hate stereotypes. Seriously, we hate them. Except that we don't. We adore stereotypes, and we desperately need them to define who we are or who we are not. People need to be able to say things like, all stereotypes are based on ignorance, because expressing such a sentiment makes them enlightened, open-minded, and incredibly unpleasant. Meanwhile, their adversaries need the ability to say such things as, like it or not, all stereotypes are ultimately based in some sort of reality, because that kind of semi-logic can justify their feelings about virtually anything. And here's what I suspect is the truth. Neither side is correct. Stereotypes are not based on fact, and they are not really based on fiction. Whenever a given stereotype seems right or wrong, it's inevitably a coincidence. The world is a prejudiced place, but it's prejudiced for the weirdest, least meaningful reasons imaginable.
刻板印象就像被恐怖分子点燃的患有艾滋病的流氓大象，而且还要更糟。我们都讨厌刻板印象。说真的，我们讨厌它们。除非不是这样。我们崇拜刻板印象，我们需要它们来定义我们是谁，或者我们不是谁。人们需要能够说出诸如“所有的刻板印象都是基于无知”这样的话，因为表达这种观点使他们显得开明、思想开放且极其令人不快。同时，他们的对手需要能够说出诸如“不管喜不喜欢，所有的刻板印象最终都是基于某种现实”这样的话，因为那种半逻辑可以证明他们对几乎任何事情的感觉。这就是我所怀疑的真相。双方都不对。刻板印象不是基于事实，也不是真的基于虚构。每当一个既定的刻板印象看起来正确或错误时，那必然是一个巧合。世界是一个充满偏见的地方，但它是出于你能想象到的最奇怪、最无意义的原因而带有偏见的。
A few years ago, I toured six German cities over a span of nine days. I was primarily struck by two points. A, the citizens of Germany are friendly and nervous. And B, the citizens of Germany perceive Americans to be obese, puritanical, non-smoking retards. Their opinion of the United States is mind-blowingly low, even when compared with how the US is viewed by France.
几年前，我九天内游览了六个德国城市。我主要对两点感到震惊。A，德国公民既友好又紧张。B，德国公民认为美国人是肥胖、清教徒、不吸烟的白痴。他们对美国的评价低得惊人，即使与法国对美国的看法相比也是如此。
Now, I can see that my reason for viewing Germans as friendly is completely unsophisticated. I believe Germans are nice because they were nice to me, which is kind of like trying to be a meteorologist by looking out a window. But at least from what I could gather, the reason German citizens assume Americans are barbaric and vapid is almost as unreasonable, even though they're usually half right.
现在，我看得出我将德国人视为友好的理由完全不成熟。我认为德国人很好，因为他们对我很好，这有点像通过窗户观察来成为气象学家。但至少据我所知，德国公民认为美国人野蛮和空虚的原因几乎同样不合理，尽管他们通常有一半是对的。
During a weekend in Frankfurt, I went to an exhibit at Schirn Kunsthalle Art Museum called I Like America. This title, as one might expect, was meant to be ironic. It's taken from a 1974 conceptual art piece called I Like America, and America Likes Me, in which German artist Joseph Beuys flew to New York and spent three days in a room with a live coyote and 50 copies of the Wall Street Journal . This piece was a European response to the destruction of Native American culture, which made about as much sense to me as it did to the coyote.
在法兰克福的一个周末，我去了席恩美术馆看了一个名为“我喜欢美国”的展览。这个标题正如人们所料，带有讽刺意味。它取自1974年一件名为“我喜欢美国，美国喜欢我”的概念艺术作品，在那件作品中，德国艺术家约瑟夫·博伊斯飞往纽约，与一只活的土狼和50份《华尔街日报》在一个房间里待了三天。这件作品是对美洲原住民文化遭到破坏的欧洲回应，这对我来说和对那只土狼来说一样让人费解。
The bulk of I Like America focused on German interest in 19th century American culture, specifically the depictions of Buffalo Bill, cowboys, and the artistic portrayal of Indians as noble savages. But it was curious to read the descriptions of what these paintings and photographs were supposed to signify. Almost all of them were alleged to illustrate some tragic flaw with American ideology. And it slowly dawned on me that the creators of I Like America had made one critical error. While they had not necessarily misunderstood the historical relationship between Americans and cowboy iconography, they totally misinterpreted its magnitude.
“我喜欢美国”的大部分内容集中在德国人对19世纪美国文化的兴趣，特别是对布法罗·比尔、牛仔的描绘，以及将印第安人作为高尚野蛮人的艺术表现。但阅读这些绘画和照片旨在象征什么的描述是很有趣的。几乎所有这些都被宣称可以说明美国意识形态的某种悲剧性缺陷。我慢慢意识到，“我喜欢美国”的创作者犯了一个严重的错误。虽然他们并没有误解美国人和牛仔肖像学之间的历史关系，但他们完全曲解了它的重要性。
With the possible exception of Jon Bon Jovi, I can't think of any modern American who gives a [BLEEP] about cowboys, even metaphorically. Dramatic Op-Ed writers are wont to criticize war hawk politicians by comparing them to John Wayne. But no one really believes the movie Hondo affects policy. It's just a shorthand way to describe something we already understand.
除了乔恩·邦·乔维，我想不出还有哪个现代美国人会在乎牛仔，即使是比喻意义上的。戏剧性的专栏作家习惯于通过将战争鹰派政客与约翰·韦恩相比来批评他们。但没人真的相信电影《原野奇侠》会影响政策。这只是一种用来描述我们已经理解的事物的简写方式。
But European intellectuals use cowboy culture to understand American sociology. And that's a specious relationship, even during moments when it almost makes sense. As it turns out, Germans care about cowboys way more than we do.
但欧洲知识分子使用牛仔文化来理解美国社会学。这是一种虚假的联系，即使在它几乎说得通的时候。事实证明，德国人比我们更关心牛仔。
A sardonic German teenager told me what she thought the phrase The American Dream meant. I assume it means watching Baywatch 24 hours a day, she said. She was sort of joking. But I've heard similar sentiments in every foreign country I've ever visited. There is widespread belief that Americans spend most of their lives watching Baywatch and MTV.
一位愤世嫉俗的德国少女告诉我她认为“美国梦”这个词意味着什么。“我猜它意味着一天24小时看《海滩护卫队》”，她说。她是在开玩笑。但在我访问过的每个外国国家，我都听过类似的观点。人们普遍认为美国人大部分时间都在看《海滩护卫队》和 MTV。
But what's interesting about this girl's insight was her reasoning. She thinks Americans love Baywatch because Joey Tribbiani on Friends loved Baywatch . And this does not mean she viewed Friends as an accurate reflection of life, nor does it suggest that she saw Matt LeBlanc as a tragic spokesman for the American working class. This was just one random detail she remembered about an American TV show she barely watched. She didn't care about this detail, and neither do we.
但这个女孩的洞察力有趣之处在于她的推理。她认为美国人喜欢《海滩护卫队》是因为《老友记》里的乔伊·崔比安尼喜欢《海滩护卫队》。这并不意味着她将《老友记》视为生活的准确反映，也不意味着她认为马特·勒布朗是美国工人阶级的悲剧代言人。这只是她记得的关于一部她几乎不看的美国电视剧的一个随机细节。她不在乎这个细节，我们也不在乎。
As I rode the train from Munich to Dresden to Hamburg, I started jotting down any random details I noticed that could prompt me to project larger truths about Germany. An abbreviated version is as follows. One, no matter how much they drink, nobody here acts drunk. Two, late-night German TV broadcasts an inordinate amount of Caucasian boxing. Three, heavy metal is still huge in this country. As proof, there's astonishingly high interest in the most recent Paul Stanley solo record. Four, when addressing customers, waiters and waitresses sometimes hold their hands behind their backs, military style. I suppose I could use these details to extrapolate various ideas about life in Germany.
当我乘火车从慕尼黑前往德累斯顿再前往汉堡时，我开始记下我注意到的任何随机细节，这些细节可能会促使我推导出关于德国的更大真相。简略版如下。一，无论他们喝多少酒，这里没人表现得喝醉了。二，深夜的德国电视会播放过量的白人拳击赛。三，重金属音乐在这个国家依然很火。作为证明，人们对保罗·斯坦利最近的个人专辑有着惊人的高兴趣。四，在与顾客交谈时，服务员有时会像军人一样把手放在背后。我想我可以用这些细节来推断关于德国生活的各种想法。
I suppose I could create allegorical value for many of these factoids, and some of my conclusions might prove true. But I am choosing not to do this. Because now, I can't help but recognize all the things people do that A, have no real significance, yet B, define how outsiders see them.
我想我可以为这些琐事创造寓言价值，而且我的一些结论可能被证明是真的。但我选择不这样做。因为现在，我不禁意识到人们所做的所有事情，A，没有真正的意义，但B，定义了外人如何看待他们。
When I returned from my tour, many people asked me what Germany was like. I said, I had no idea. But weren't you just there, they inevitably asked? Yes, I told them, I was just there, and I don't know what it's like at all.
当我结束旅程回来时，很多人问我德国是什么样的。我说，我不知道。但你不是刚从那儿回来吗，他们不可避免地问。是的，我告诉他们，我刚从那儿回来，而且我一点也不知道它是什么样的。
Chuck Klosterman. A version of this first appeared in Esquire Magazine. Chuck Klosterman is the author of many fine nonfiction books. And his very first novel, Downtown Owl, comes out this September.
查克·克洛斯特曼。本文的一个版本最初出现在《时尚先生》杂志上。查克·克洛斯特曼是许多优秀非虚构类书籍的作者。他的第一部小说《市中心猫头鹰》将于今年九月出版。
[SONG - "WANTED DEAD OR ALIVE" BY BON JOVI]
[歌曲 - 邦·乔维的《Wanted Dead or Alive》]
Act Three, Yes, No, or Baby. Well, there's a simple rule designed to help us all fight the urge to pigeonhole other people based on a first impression. And I speak, of course, of don't judge a book by its cover. But this axiom, this adage, this maxim is deeply flawed and not just because of its annoyingly scoldy self-righteousness. The fact is, there are times in life where you must judge a person based on woefully little information-- crammed into some cover letter, or something like that-- that they have put together. One of our show's producers, Nancy Updike, visited somebody in this very judgey situation.
第三幕，是、否或宝贝。嗯，有一条简单的规则旨在帮助我们所有人克服根据第一印象给他人贴标签的冲动。当然，我说的是“人不可貌相”。但这条格言、这句老话、这句箴言存在严重缺陷，不仅是因为它那令人讨厌的说教式自以为是。事实是，生活中确实有这样的时候，你必须根据可怜的少量信息——塞在某份求职信里，或者类似的东西——来判断一个人。我们节目的一位制片人南希·厄普代克，探访了一位正处于这种评判困境的人。
Anyone who's not a megalomaniac feels daunted by the prospect of having to separate a group of strangers into a yes pile and a no pile. Kim [? Schwary ?] is seven months pregnant. And she's facing, on her coffee table in Seattle, dozens of one-page letters from couples who want to adopt her baby. Individually, each letter seems like not enough information. And collectively, they are way, way too much. The first time she read through them, they melted into an indistinguishable mass of thoughtful, intelligent, fun-loving, mutually supportive, healthy, active, outdoorsy couples.
任何不是狂妄自大的人都会因为要将一群陌生人分成“是”和“否”两堆而感到畏惧。金·施瓦里怀孕七个月了。她在西雅图的咖啡桌上，面对着几十封来自想领养她孩子的夫妇的一页信。单独来看，每封信提供的信息似乎都不够。而合在一起，它们又实在是太多太多了。她第一次阅读这些信时，它们融合成了一大堆难以区分的贴心、聪明、热爱生活、相互支持、健康、积极、热爱户外的夫妇。
A lot of the hobbies are similar, just hiking-- it's couples from the Northwest too. I'm sure that's common. Even just this page, hiking, snowshoeing, camping.
许多爱好都很相似，只是徒步旅行——这也来自西北地区的夫妇。我相信这很常见。即使只是这一页，徒步旅行、雪鞋行走、露营。
And if you turn to the next page, is there also a hiking part?
如果你翻到下一页，也有徒步旅行的部分吗？
Let's see, probably. Oh, yes. Hiking, there you go.
看看，大概吧。哦，是的。徒步旅行，在那儿呢。
Kim's doing an open adoption, which means that she will have a relationship with the family who adopts her child for the rest of her life. The cover letters are just the beginning of a long, long process. The whole thing is sort of like super high-stakes online dating. Judging people is required. Kim goes back and forth between practical considerations and pure gut checks.
金正在进行开放式领养，这意味着她将与收养她孩子的家庭保持一辈子的关系。求职信（这里指领养申请信）只是漫长过程的开始。这一切就像是一场赌注极高的在线约会。评判他人是必要的。金在实际考虑和纯粹的直觉之间来回摇摆。
Here's something. This couple has another child. And they're talking-- I don't know, they use kind of like child-talk when they're talking about him. Like, it says something about kissing his boo-boos, or something. And that kind of-- I don't know. I don't like that very much.
这儿有一些东西。这对夫妇有另一个孩子。他们在谈论——我不知道，他们在谈论他时使用了一种孩子气的语言。比如，它说了一些关于亲吻他的伤口之类的。那种……我不知道。我不太喜欢那样。
Kim ends up liking a different couple that already has a little boy. She likes the idea that her baby would have a sibling. She weeds out a family that seems to her too religious. And later, she frowns on a couple who both have high-powered jobs that they write about at length. She wonders if they'd be home enough for the baby.
金最终喜欢上了另一对已经有个小男孩的夫妇。她喜欢她的孩子会有一个兄弟姐妹的想法。她淘汰了一个她认为宗教色彩太浓的家庭。后来，她对一对都拥有高管工作并在信中长篇大论的夫妇皱起了眉头。她怀疑他们是否有足够的时间陪伴孩子。
These guys, I could see them working 50, 60 hours a week because of their careers.
这些人，我能想象他们因为职业原因每周工作50、60个小时。
A few pages later, Kim makes a face when a couple says they're relational people.
几页之后，当一对夫妇说他们是“关系导向型”的人时，金做了一个鬼脸。
I'm wondering exactly what that meant. There's this whole packet of information. And then I'll focus on this sentence that maybe I don't like. And that makes me feel like I'm really kind of judgmental when I do this. And sometimes that doesn't always feel good. See? And this is something really small. But for some reason, it's-- it says, the opportunity to have a relationship with the child's biological heritage is very important, including medical history. That feels kind of weird to me.
我想知道那确切意味着什么。有这一整包的信息。然后我会专注于我可能不喜欢的一个句子。这让我觉得当我这样做时，我真的很有评判性。有时这感觉并不好。看？这是一个很小的东西。但出于某种原因，它——它说，与孩子生物学血统建立关系的机会非常重要，包括医疗记录。这对我来说感觉有点奇怪。
It's a little clinical.
有点临床化。
Right, it is a little clinical. I want to be more than medical records. So--
没错，确实有点临床化。我想我不仅仅是医疗记录。所以——
So that kind of put you off, right there?
所以那让你退缩了，就在那一刻？
Yeah. So it goes back to that judgmental thing, because I've written things. And maybe that's not how they meant to portray themselves. But it does, like you said, sound very clinical. Yeah.
是的。所以这又回到了那种评判性的东西上，因为我也写过东西。也许那不是他们想要描绘自己的方式。但正如你所说，听起来确实非常临床化。是的。
Just like Kim's having to quickly peg these families-- extrapolating all sorts of important things from just words on a page and a few pictures-- she's finding that as a single woman pregnant, people are making all kinds of assumptions about her. Co-workers assume she's married and starting a family. Those are awkward conversations. And if she tells someone what's really going on, that she's putting the baby up for adoption, she had better be prepared for a lecture.
就像金必须迅速给这些家庭贴上标签——仅仅从纸上的文字和几张照片推断出各种重要的事情——她发现作为一个怀孕的单身女性，人们也在对她做出各种假设。同事们假设她结婚了并正在组建家庭。那些谈话很尴尬。如果她告诉某人真正发生了什么，她要把孩子送去领养，她最好准备好接受说教。
You're really kind of vulnerable when you're pregnant. And you're vulnerable to judgment, I guess. People are very prone to-- once you say what you're doing-- they tell you what they would do and not do. And they want to be like, oh, I think you're going to be really upset. And I think this. And I'm like, no, I think maybe you're the one who's upset, not me.
你怀孕的时候真的很脆弱。我想，你很容易受到评判。人们非常倾向于——一旦你说出你在做什么——他们会告诉你他们会做什么和不会做什么。他们想说，哦，我觉得你会非常难过。我觉得这。而我会说，不，我觉得也许是你难过，而不是我。
She says some people are utterly convinced that adoption is just a bad idea all around, which Kim takes personally since she was adopted. It's one of the reasons she didn't want to get an abortion.
她说有些人完全确信领养在各方面都是一个坏主意，金对此很介意，因为她自己就是被领养的。这也是她不想堕胎的原因之一。
People feel that if you're adopted that you have this great sense of loss, or you just don't know who you are, and there's an identity crisis, and you feel abandoned. And that's not how I felt with my experience.
人们觉得如果你被领养了，你就会有一种巨大的失落感，或者你根本不知道你是谁，并且会有身份危机，你感到被遗弃。而那不是我经历中的感受。
Being adopted?
作为被领养者？
Being adopted, exactly. I felt very loved by my parents. The baby's father told me that he thought that-- I don't know why he said this, but he kind of assumed and said this-- that he was so much closer to his parents than I was to mine, which isn't true at all. And that's how he felt things must be.
作为被领养者，没错。我感到父母非常爱我。孩子的父亲告诉我，他认为——我不知道他为什么这么说，但他有点假设并说了这个——他和他父母的关系比我和我的父母要亲密得多，而这根本不是真的。他觉得事情一定是那样。
I waited until just about the end of my interview with Kim to confess that I'd had her pegged all wrong before I spoke to her. I thought she'd be a teenager, confused. But Kim is 27, has her own apartment, a good job.
我等到采访金快结束时才坦白，在和她交谈之前，我完全看错了她。我以为她会是一个困惑的青少年。但金27岁了，有自己的公寓，一份不错的工作。
Right. I'm in a situation where it would be very feasible that I would raise the child on my own. So it's probably harder to understand.
没错。我所处的环境，我自己抚养孩子是非常可行的。所以这可能更难理解。
OK, so people are making that judgment about you. What don't they know about you that would make them understand?
好的，所以人们在对你做出那种评判。关于你，有什么他们不知道的事情能让他们理解吗？
I don't know. I have these unusual circumstances, that I was engaged and my fiance passed away. And after that, I kind of think I was lonely and looking for someone. And I feel like I made a mistake. And I still miss my fiance and think about him all the time. And I just don't feel like I'm emotionally ready to raise a child. I feel like I could, but I just feel like it's not the right time.
我不知道。我有这些不同寻常的情况，我订过婚，但我的未婚夫去世了。在那之后，我想我有点孤独，在寻找某人。我觉得我犯了一个错误。我仍然想念我的未婚夫，一直想起他。我只是觉得我在情感上还没有准备好抚养一个孩子。我觉得我可以，但我只是觉得现在不是合适的时机。
Especially if it's something that you guys talked about doing together. And here you are.
特别是如果那是你们本来打算一起做的事情。而现在你却一个人。
Right, exactly. We were always going to have kids together. And here I am being all single and pregnant with some guy, this just kind of insignificant fellow. And certainly things aren't going the way that they were supposed to, or as planned.
对，没错。我们本来一直打算一起要孩子的。而现在我却单身怀孕，和一个家伙，这个有点无关紧要的人。当然，事情并没有像它们本该发生的那样，或者像计划的那样。
Kim doesn't go into her reasons with most people. So they make assumptions about her that she doesn't bother to correct. And she flips through dozens of letters from couples and makes assumptions about them that they'll never get a chance to respond to. It's the way of the world. Everyone's a judge, and everyone's the accused. And every day, things aren't going the way they were supposed to or as planned.
金大多数时候不会告诉别人她的原因。所以他们对她做出假设，而她懒得纠正。她翻看几十封来自夫妇的信，并对他们做出他们永远没有机会回应的假设。这就是世界的方式。每个人都是法官，每个人也是被告。而每天，事情都没有按本该发生的或计划的那样进行。
Nancy Updike. Coming up, proof that some people simply should not go on vacation. They can't hack it. They can not handle the mellow. That is in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克。接下来，证据显示有些人根本就不该去度假。他们应付不来。他们无法享受安逸。那就在一分钟后，从芝加哥公共电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Got You Pegged. Stories of people making grand assumptions about other people, sometimes correct, sometimes deeply incorrect.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“我把你定型了”。讲述人们对他人做出宏大假设的故事，有时正确，有时深陷错误。
We've arrived at act four of our show. Act Four, Paradise Lost. There are certain settings-- as we've said on the show already-- where making judgments about people from tiny amounts of evidence is kind of required-- if you're interviewing somebody for a job, if you are choosing who is going to adopt your baby. Being on vacation is not one of those situations. But some people really never can stop the judging, like, apparently, one of our regular contributors, Shalom Auslander.
我们已经到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，失落的天堂。正如我们在节目中已经说过的，某些环境下——如果你正在面试某人，如果你正在选择谁要领养你的孩子——根据极少量证据对人做出判断是某种必需的。度假不是那种情况。但有些人真的永远无法停止评判，就像我们的一位常客，沙洛姆·奥斯兰德，显然也是这样。
I ruin vacations. That's just what I do. In Greece, I was sure the hotel had stuck us with the worst room in the building, even though every room was identical. I know that because we switched three times the day we got there. We switched again the morning after, and went home two days early. A year later, I spent four days in a Jamaican rain forest complaining about the weather. We're in a rain forest, my wife said. So? So it rains. We went home two days early.
我毁掉了假期。这就是我做的。在希腊，我确信酒店给了我们楼里最差的房间，尽管每个房间都一模一样。我知道那是因为我们到的那天换了三次。第二天早上我们又换了，并提前两天回家了。一年后，我在牙买加雨林待了四天，抱怨天气。我们在雨林里，我妻子说。那又怎样？所以它会下雨。我们提前两天回家了。
And so last year, when my wife informed me that she had booked us a six-day vacation in Anguilla, a remote island in the British West Indies, I decided that this time would be different. It was our first trip in a while, and I'd been doing a lot of work on myself. With the money I'd spent on therapy, I could have bought the whole damn island of Anguilla. So I was anxious to see how far I'd come.
所以去年，当我妻子通知我她为我们预订了在安圭拉岛的六天假期，那是英属西印度群岛中一个偏远的岛屿时，我决定这次会不同。这是我们一段时间以来的第一次旅行，我一直在进行自我建设。我花在心理治疗上的钱，本来可以买下整个该死的安圭拉岛。所以我很想看看我进步了多少。
The resort was far more expensive than we could afford. I suspected that my wife was hoping that an exclusive resort would minimize the number of disappointments that could inevitably set me off. There was no need for her to worry. This time would be different. This time, I would be different.
度假村远比我们负担得起的价格要贵。我怀疑我妻子是希望一个独特的度假村能尽量减少那些不可避免地让我爆发的失望。她不用担心。这次会不同。这次，我会不同。
The resort we flew to sits tucked away on the eastern end of an utterly pristine inlet of blue-green water on the southern tip of the island. The bellman brought our bags into our room, warned us not to feed the iguanas, wished us a happy stay, and left. My son started jumping on the bed, my wife joined him, and I pulled open the wooden louvered patio doors that led out to the beach.
我们飞往的度假村坐落在岛屿南端一个非常原始的蓝绿色水湾的东端。行李员把我们的行李搬进房间，警告我们不要喂鬣蜥，祝我们住得愉快，然后离开了。我儿子开始在床上跳，我妻子加入了，我拉开了通往海滩的木制百叶窗露台门。
Wow, I said, as I stepped out onto the patio. For once, the view looked exactly as it had on the website. Pelicans circled above the calm, still waters. The owner's golden retrievers slept peacefully in the shade beneath a gentle, spreading palm. My wife came up behind me and put her arms around my waist. It's Eden, she said. Paradise, I answered. Not a cloud in the sky, she said. Not a single cloud, I said. And then she went inside.
哇，我说，当我踏上露台时。风景看起来和网站上一模一样。鹈鹕在平静、静止的水面上盘旋。主人的金毛寻回犬在蔓延的棕榈树下的阴凉处安详地睡觉。我妻子走到我身后，环住我的腰。这是伊甸园，她说。天堂，我回答。天上一片云都没有，她说。一片云都没有，我说。然后她进屋了。
When I came in, she already had her beach bag packed and was pulling a T-shirt over our son's head. We're going to the beach, she said. You coming? I'll come down after I unpack, I said. They hurried out the door, dropped a cracker for the iguana waiting in the shade at the bottom of the steps, and headed down to the beach. I quickly put away our clothing, grabbed the room key, and locked the patio door as I closed it behind me.
当我进去时，她已经收拾好了沙滩包，正把一件T恤套在我儿子头上。“我们要去海滩，”她说。“你要来吗？”“我整理完行李就下去，”我说。他们匆匆走出门口，给等在台阶下阴凉处的鬣蜥扔了一块饼干，朝海滩走去。我迅速整理好衣服，抓起房门钥匙，在我身后锁上了露台门。
Hello, said the old man. He was standing at the foot of our patio, holding on to the rail for support. Oh, hello, I said. His name was Marvin, and he'd been coming to the resort for 25 years. Oh, 25 years at least, he said. Maybe more, such a long time ago. Let's see, I'm 81 now. Yeah, the first time I came here was in, oh, let's see, 1980, I believe. Really, I said, backing my way towards the beach.
“你好，”老人说。他站在我们露台脚下，扶着栏杆支撑身体。“哦，你好，”我说。他的名字叫马文，他已经连续25年来这个度假村了。“哦，至少25年了，”他说。“可能更多，很久以前的事了。让我想想，我现在81岁了。是的，我第一次来这里是在，哦，让我想想，1980年，我想。真的吗，”我说，一边向海滩倒退。“
Here's the thing about people. I don't really like them. That's why I find racism so curious. There are so many reasons to dislike people. You're going to go with color? So I avoid the people whenever possible and try to keep my distance. It's really better for everyone.
这就是关于人的地方。我不怎么喜欢他们。这就是为什么我觉得种族主义很奇怪。有太多的理由去讨厌人。你非要按肤色来？所以我尽可能避开人，并尝试保持距离。这对每个人都更好。
Could have been 1982, Marvin continued, or maybe even 1978, now that I think about it. No, no, it was 1980. I remember because I was arguing with my wife about Reagan. Whoo boy, did she hate him. Uh-huh, I said. I looked toward the beach and could see my wife and son running down to the water with his pail and shovel. Well, I better go. Family's waiting for me and all. She's dead now, he said. He gently cleared his throat and looked to the ground. Damn it, I thought. I'm sorry, I said. She was a good woman, he said. I nodded. I'm sure, I said.
“可能是1982年，”马文继续说，“或者甚至1978年，现在我想起来了。不，不，是1980年。我记得因为我当时在和妻子吵关于里根的事。天哪，她多讨厌他。”“嗯哼，”我说。我望向海滩，可以看到我的妻子和儿子拿着小桶和铲子朝水边跑去。“好吧，我得走了。家人在等我什么的。”“她现在去世了，”他说。他轻轻清了清嗓子，看向地面。“该死，”我心想。“我很遗憾，”我说。“她是个好女人，”他说。我点点头。“我相信，”我说。“
The hotel was very different back then, of course, Marvin continued. Very, very different. The restaurant wasn't where it is now. No, sir. That building wasn't even built until 1990, or so. Maybe '92, even. A fellow named Jeremiah built it with his own two hands, by gosh. Nobody builds like that anymore. As Marvin rambled on, I began to wonder, was there any way I could switch rooms without upsetting my wife? But I stopped myself, pulled myself together. Not this time, I thought. We are having a pleasant vacation.
“那时候酒店很不一样，当然，”马文继续说。“非常，非常不一样。餐厅不在现在这个地方。不，先生。那栋楼直到1990年左右才建成。甚至可能是92年。一个叫杰里米的人用他自己的双手建成的，天哪。现在没人那样盖房子了。”当马文喋喋不休时，我开始怀疑，有没有什么办法能在不惹恼我妻子的前提下换房间？但我阻止了自己，调整了心态。不是这次，我想。我们要度过一个愉快的假期。
Is that your wife, Marvin asked. Yeah, I said, waiting for me. She's beautiful, said Marvin. Yeah, I said. Well, I better skedaddle. My wife was beautiful too. Uh-huh, I said with a wave. Well, I'll see you later. Marvin waved back, walked up the steps of the villa directly adjoining ours, took out his key and walked inside. The door closed and the expectorating began. [COUGHING] Damn it, I thought.
“那是你妻子吗，”马文问。“是的，”我说，“在等我。”“她很美，”马文说。“是的，”我说。“好吧，我得开溜了。我妻子也很美。”“嗯哼，”我挥手说，“好吧，回头见。”马文挥手回应，走上我们隔壁别墅的台阶，拿出钥匙走了进去。门关上了，吐痰声开始了。[咳嗽] 该死，我心想。
The trip had exhausted our son, so we had an early dinner and went for a short sunset stroll on the beach. Thanks, said my wife, putting her arm through mine. For what, I asked. For being so good about things. I smiled and squeezed her arm. Our son ran through the gentle surf and shrieked with joy. Soon he grew tired, climbed into my wife's arms, and we reluctantly climbed the patio steps back to the room. Good night, said Marvin. He was sitting on his patio next door. Good night, whispered my wife.
这次旅行让我儿子筋疲力尽，所以我们早早吃了晚餐，去海滩散了会儿夕阳步。“谢谢，”我妻子说，把手臂挽进我的。“谢什么，”我问。“因为你对事情的处理这么好。”我微笑着捏了捏她的手臂。我儿子在温柔的浪花中奔跑，尖叫着欢呼。很快他累了，爬进我妻子的怀里，我们不情愿地爬上露台台阶回到房间。“晚安，”马文说。他正坐在隔壁的露台上。“晚安，”我妻子低声说。
Where in New York are you from, asked Martin. Upstate, she whispered, as she carried our exhausted son into the room. I spent a lot of time there, said Marvin. Hudson Valley, I think it was. Might have been the Catskills. Yeah, I think it was the Catskills. My wife and I used to take our kids up there when they were younger. OK, I whispered. We don't talk much anymore. My kids, I mean, not my wife. She's dead. Sure, I whispered. Well, good night. I closed the door behind me and locked it. Jesus Christ, I said. You OK, asked my wife. I'm fine, I said, with a smile.
“你们是从纽约哪里来的，”马丁问。“上州，”她低声说，把精疲力竭的儿子抱进房间。“我在那儿待过很长时间，”马文说。“哈德逊河谷，我想是。可能是卡茨基尔山。是的，我想是卡茨基尔山。我妻子和我以前在孩子小的时候经常带他们去那儿。”“好吧，”我低声说。“我们不再多说话了。我的孩子们，我是说，不是我妻子。她去世了。”“当然，”我低声说。“好吧，晚安。”我锁上身后的门。天哪，我说。“你还好吗，”我妻子问。“我很好，”我说，带着微笑。
We put our son to bed, crept quietly out the back door, and lay down together on a lounge chair underneath the stars. I love you, said my wife. I love you too, I answered. [CLEARING THROAT] came the sound from next door. [COUGHING] We lay there a while longer, holding hands in the cool, tropical night breeze, watching the shimmering lights of long dead stars, and pretending we weren't listening to an old man drowning in his own phlegm. [COUGHING]
我们把儿子哄睡，静静地溜出后门，在星空下的躺椅上躺在一起。“我爱你，”我妻子说。“我也爱你，”我回答。[清嗓声] 从隔壁传来。[咳嗽] 我们在那里躺了一会儿，在凉爽的热带夜风中牵着手，看着早已死去的星星的闪烁光芒，假装我们没有在听一个老人在他自己的痰中窒息。[咳嗽]
I awoke the following morning in a dark mood. I didn't want my wife to see it, so I crept out of bed, quietly dressed, and went for a walk. I made my way to the open air restaurant that overlooked the sea and sat down for an early breakfast. OK, I thought, so there's an old man next door. Was that worth ruining our whole vacation? I'd worked too long and too hard on myself to be derailed by this.
第二天早晨，我在黑暗的情绪中醒来。我不希望我妻子看到，所以我溜出床，安静地穿好衣服，去散步了。我走向俯瞰大海的露天餐厅，坐下来吃早饭。好吧，我想，所以隔壁有个老头。这值得毁掉我们的整个假期吗？我花了太长时间、太努力地进行自我改善，不能被这事脱轨。
I decided to view Marvin as some sort of a test. Maybe it was God's test. Maybe it was just fate. But I was stronger than Marvin. I was stronger than 1,000 Marvins. He would not defeat me. I finished my breakfast and walked back to the room.
我决定把马文视为某种测试。也许是上帝的测试。也许只是命运。但我比马文强。我比一千个马文还要强。他不会打败我。我吃完早餐，走回房间。
Good morning, said Marvin. He was sitting at his patio table, finishing his breakfast. Good morning, I said. A lovely day, isn't it? Oh, it is, he said. Mornings like this, my wife and I used to get up early and go for a long swim. That sounds nice, I said. She's dead now, he said. Hey, I said, who isn't? That's true, said Marvin. I looked out over the beach and smiled. Check and mate, Marv. I was unflappable.
“早安，”马文说。他正坐在露台桌旁吃早餐。“早安，”我说。“天气不错，不是吗？”“哦，是啊，”他说。“这样的早晨，我和我妻子过去常常早起去游泳。”“听起来不错，”我说。“她现在去世了，”他说。“嘿，”我说，“谁不是呢？”“那倒是，”马文说。我望向海滩，微笑了。将军，马文。我是临危不乱的。
Auschwitz, said Marvin. I turned around. Sorry? My wife, she died in Auschwitz. We were quite young, only married a few years. Auschwitz, I said. Marvin nodded. We were sent to Dachau at first. But after a few weeks, they sent us to Auschwitz. Auschwitz, I said. Sure, my mother too. She was sent to Bergen-Belsen, but that's not where she died. She died in Auschwitz with my father. Probably had pneumonia. That's what I heard. My father was shot. The Nazis shot him. I know this from some people in Miami who knew him in the camps. Ethel and Morris Goldstein. They died a while ago.
“奥斯威辛，”马文说。我转过身。“对不起？”“我的妻子，她死在奥斯威辛。我们很年轻，结婚才几年。”“奥斯威辛，”我说。马文点点头。“我们起初被送到达豪。但在几周后，他们把我们送到了奥斯威辛。”“奥斯威辛，”我说。“当然，我妈妈也是。她被送到卑尔根-贝尔森，但她不是死在那里。她和我爸爸死在奥斯威辛。可能得了肺炎。那是我的耳闻。我爸爸被枪杀了。纳粹枪杀了他。我从迈阿密的一些在集中营认识他的人那里知道这件事。埃塞尔和莫里斯·戈德斯坦。他们很久以前就去世了。”
I should have been compassionate, I know. I should have taken a pad and pen and committed his story to paper for future generations. But I didn't. Instead, I seethed. 20 minutes of genocide stories later, I went into our villa, closed the doors sharply behind me, and stood in the center of the room with my hands on my hips. What, asked my wife. I threw my hand into the air. Auschwitz, I said. Pardon? Auschwitz. What are you talking about, she asked. Au-freaking-schwitz. He's a survivor, hon. A Holocaust survivor.
我本该有同情心，我知道。我本该拿纸笔把他的故事写下来留给后代。但我没有。相反，我怒不可遏。20分钟的种族灭绝故事之后，我走进别墅，重重地关上门，双手叉腰站在房间中央。“怎么了，”我妻子问。我把手往空中一扔。“奥斯威辛，”我说。“什么？”“奥斯威辛。”“你在说什么，”她问。“奥——该死的——斯威辛。他是幸存者，亲爱的。一个大屠杀幸存者。”
I don't have anything against Holocaust survivors. Some of my best friends are Holocaust survivors. OK, that's not actually true. But I don't have anything against them. But if I want to relax and forget about life for a while, maybe hit a bar and have a drink, I'm not going to call Elie Wiesel. Hey, Elie, how's it going? I had a tough day. Why don't you come over and we'll watch Schindler's List? Bring beer.
我不反对大屠杀幸存者。我最好的朋友里有些是大屠杀幸存者。好吧，那其实不是真的。但我不反对他们。但如果我想放松一下，暂时忘记生活，也许去酒吧喝一杯，我不会给埃利·威塞尔打电话。“嘿，埃利，怎么样？我今天过得很糟。为什么你不过来，我们看《辛德勒的名单》？带上啤酒。”
A Holocaust survivor, I said, pacing back and forth across the room. The place is half empty, and the guy next door is a Holocaust survivor. I think I've been pretty good about this. I didn't let the travel upset me. I didn't let the hacking next door all night long get to me. But this is too much. It's too much. I'm standing in paradise talking about gas chambers.
“一个大屠杀幸存者，”我说，在房间里来回踱步。“这里一半是空的，隔壁那家伙是个大屠杀幸存者。我觉得我已经表现得很好了。我没有让行程扰乱我。我没有让隔壁整夜的咳嗽声影响我。但这太过分了。太过分了。我站在天堂里讨论毒气室。”
My wife was sympathetic, but she'd seen this before and insisted I was blowing it out of proportion. As usual, she said. And I said, what's that supposed to mean? And she said, you know what that means. And I said, no, I don't. And less than 24 hours after our plane touched down in Eden, we were fighting.
我妻子很有同情心，但她以前见过这种场面，并坚持认为我是在小题大做。“一如既往，”她说。我问，“那是什么意思？”她说，“你知道那是什么意思。”我说，“不，我不知道。”在我们到达伊甸园不到24小时后，我们就吵架了。
It's your decision, she said to me, as she gathered her beach things together. He's not ruining our vacation, you are. No I'm not, I shouted. Goebbels is. Blame Goebbels. She walked out and stomped down the patio steps. My son began to cry. A dozen iguanas sat on the deck. Two of them ran inside and hid under the bed. Damn it, I thought.
“这是你的决定，”她一边收拾沙滩用品一边对我说。“他没有毁掉我们的假期，是你。不，我没有，”我大喊。“戈培尔才是。去怪戈培尔。”她走出去，跺着脚走下露台台阶。我儿子开始哭。十几只鬣蜥坐在甲板上。其中两只跑进屋里躲在床下。该死，我心想。
I spent the next few hours avoiding my wife, hoping that a little time would settle things down between us. I took my son and walked over to the front office. Did you feed them, the man asked. We told you not to feed them. They're in our room, I said. They're under our bed.
接下来的几个小时我都在避开我妻子，希望时间能平息我们之间的矛盾。我带着儿子走到前台。“你喂它们了吗，”那人问。“我们告诉过你不要喂它们。它们在我们的房间里，”我说。“它们躲在我们的床底下。”
I heard laughter coming from the lobby and poked my head around the corner. Marvin was sitting in a wicker chair, surrounded by a half a dozen adoring hotel employees. A waiter from the bar brought him a rum punch. Let me pay you, said Marvin. No, no, Mr. Marvin, said the waiter. No, no.
我听到从大堂传来笑声，探头一看。马文正坐在柳条椅上，被半打崇拜他的酒店员工包围。酒吧的一位服务员给他端来一杯朗姆潘趣酒。“让我付钱，”马文说。“不，不，马文先生，”服务员说。“不，不。”
If there's anything worse than hating someone, it's discovering that everyone else loves them. Oh, Mr. Marvin, an attractive female chambermaid cried, he's terrible. The man at the front desk smiled in Marvin's direction. What a sweet man, he said, and then shook his head. And what he's been through.
如果有什么比恨一个人更糟糕，那就是发现其他人都在爱他。“哦，马文先生，”一位迷人的女客房服务员喊道，他太可怜了。前台的男人朝着马文的方向微笑着。多么甜蜜的人，他说，然后摇了摇头。而且他经历了那么多。
At dinner that evening, Marvin sat at the resort owner's table. My wife and I sat nearby, barely talking. Marvin told funny stories, and everyone laughed. Marvin told sad stories-- about the Holocaust I guessed, judging by the horror on the face of his dinner companions-- and everyone hugged him. And when the bill came and Marvin reached for it, again, they refused to let him pay. That was when I decided, with absolute certainty, that the son of a bitch was faking it.
那天晚上吃晚餐时，马文坐在度假村主人的桌旁。我和妻子坐在附近，几乎没说话。马文讲有趣的故事，大家都在笑。马文讲悲伤的故事——我猜是关于大屠杀的，看着他同桌用餐者脸上的恐惧——大家都拥抱他。当账单来了，马文伸手去拿时，他们再次拒绝让他付钱。就在那时，我断定，那个狗娘养的是装的。
Holocaust survivor my ass, I thought. I grew up in an Orthodox Jewish community. I've known Holocaust survivors, OK? And they don't go on and on about it. Elie Wiesel doesn't go on about it. Marvin was no Holocaust survivor. He was just an old chatterbox looking for a meal ticket. There's no such thing as a free lunch until you tell everyone sitting next to you at lunch about your stay in Bergen-Belsen.
“什么大屠杀幸存者，去他的，”我想。我在一个正统犹太社区长大。我知道大屠杀幸存者，好吗？他们不会没完没了地谈论它。埃利·威塞尔就不会没完没了地谈论它。马文根本不是什么大屠杀幸存者。他只是一个找饭票的老碎嘴。在你告诉午餐桌旁的所有人关于你在卑尔根-贝尔森的经历之前，世上没有免费的午餐。
Marvin was faking, I was sure of it. And I was equally sure that if I could just prove that to my wife, all would be forgiven. And I knew just how to do it.
马文在装，我确信。而且我也同样确信，只要我能向我妻子证明这一点，一切都会得到原谅。我知道怎么做。
We came back from dinner and I put my son into his pajamas and read him some stories. My wife sang him some songs and put him to bed. And after that, she put on her shoes and said she needed to take a walk. Fine, I said. Good, she answered. Great, I said. Whatever, she replied.
我们吃完晚饭回来，我给儿子穿上睡衣读了些故事。我妻子给他唱了几首歌哄他入睡。之后，她穿上鞋说她需要出去走走。“好吧，”我说。“好，”她回答。“太棒了，”我说。“随便，”她回复。
I went outside, sat down on the patio steps, and watched the ocean, hoping it would calm me down. Suddenly, I heard a groan coming from Marvin's patio. I stood up, peeked over the fence that separated our two patios, and saw him asleep on one of his lounge chairs. This was my chance.
我走到外面，坐在露台台阶上，看着大海，希望它能让我平静下来。突然，我听到从马文的露台传来一声呻吟。我站起来，偷看隔开我们两个露台的围栏，看到他睡在其中一张躺椅上。这是我的机会。
I looked around to see if anyone was watching, went over to his patio, and crept up the stairs. He rustled, and I froze. After a few seconds, I tiptoed over to where he was sleeping. His left arm was propped behind his head, but his right arm was stretched out along the arm of the chair. Bingo. I made my way back to our room and waited anxiously for my wife to return.
我环顾四周看看有没有人看，走到他的露台，蹑手蹑脚地走上楼梯。他动了动，我僵住了。几秒钟后，我踮着脚尖走到他睡觉的地方。他的左手臂撑在头后，但他的右手臂伸在椅子的扶手上。宾果。我走回我们的房间，焦虑地等待我妻子的归来。
A few minutes later, the front door opened. Well, well, well, I said, as she came into the room. Well, well, what, she asked. Well, well, well, I guess Mr. Auschwitz isn't such a survivor after all. What are you talking about, she asked. I held my arm out and pointed to my forearm. No numbers, I said with a smile. At last, I'd gotten a clean look at his forearm, and no numbers. What, asked my wife. No numbers. If he was in the Holocaust, where are the numbers?
几分钟后，前台的门开了。“嗯，嗯，嗯，”当她进屋时，我说。“嗯，嗯，什么，”她问。“嗯，嗯，嗯，我猜奥斯威辛先生毕竟不是什么幸存者。”“你在说什么，”她问。我伸出手臂，指着我的前臂。“没有编号，”我微笑着说。最后，我清楚地看到了他的前臂，没有编号。“什么，”我妻子问。“没有编号。如果他在大屠杀中，编号在哪里？”
Her face dropped. What did you do, she asked. What? What did you do? I didn't do anything. Did you ask him to show you his numbers? Bloody hell, Shal, did you ask him to show you his numbers? I didn't ask him to show me his numbers, I said. He was sleeping.
她的脸沉了下来。“你做了什么，”她问。“什么？你做了什么？”“我什么都没做。你让他给你看他的编号了吗？该死，沙尔，你让他给你看编号了吗？”“我没让他给我看编号，”我说。“他在睡觉。”
She pressed her fingertips against her eyes and shook her head. And why exactly would he lie about being in the Holocaust? Why, I asked. Free stuff. They pay for all his meals. They probably pay for his room. He's faking it. This is ludicrous. Why would he pick the Holocaust? What's he going to say, Bataan Death March? It was a hike. Get over it. You want free stuff, you go with Holocaust.
她用指尖按住眼睛，摇了摇头。“他到底为什么要在大屠杀这件事上撒谎？为什么，”我问。“免费的东西。他们支付他所有的餐费。他们可能付他的房费。他是装的。这太荒谬了。他为什么选大屠杀？他要说什么，巴丹死亡行军？那是一次远足。算了吧。如果你想要免费的东西，你会选大屠杀。”
Which arm, she asked. What? Which arm did you check? I paused. The right one, I said. She looked at me. They tattooed the left? She nodded. And they didn't tattoo everyone. How do you know? My neighbors were survivors, she said. Both neighbors. None of them had numbers. She kicked her shoes off and headed for the bathroom. This isn't about Marvin, she said. This isn't about numbers or concentration camps. This is about you.
“哪只胳膊，”她问。“什么？你检查了哪只胳膊？”我停顿了一下。“右边，”我说。她看着我。“他们纹在左边？”她点点头。“而且他们没有纹每个人。你怎么知道？”“我的邻居是幸存者，”她说。“两个邻居。他们都没有编号。”她踢掉鞋子朝浴室走去。“这与马文无关，”她说。“这与编号或集中营无关。这是关于你。”
All that night and into the next morning, I couldn't sleep. I lay in bed, imagining that I'd prove to everyone what a fraud Marvin was. I pictured finding a photo of him, circa 1940, somewhere in Miami. I pictured calling the Holocaust Museum in DC. Marvin, they would say. We have no record of a Marvin. I pictured confronting him at dinner, catching him out on some esoteric German historical fact. Wrong, Himmler didn't take over the Gestapo until 1934. Ha. But mostly, I just felt awful. A full third of our first family vacation was over, and we'd spent most of it fighting. I was sure our son sensed it, sure that he would hold it against me, sure I was wrong, but sure I was right.
那天晚上一直到第二天早晨，我都没能睡着。我躺在床上，想象着我向每个人证明马文是一个骗子。我想象着找到他在1940年左右的照片，在迈阿密的某个地方。我想象着给华盛顿特区的大屠杀纪念馆打电话。“马文，”他们会说。“我们没有马文的记录。”我想象着在晚餐时与他对质，揭穿他关于某个深奥的德国历史事实。“错了，希姆莱直到1934年才接管盖世太保。哈。”但大多时候，我只是感到糟糕透顶。我们的第一次家庭度假已经过去三分之一了，我们大部分时间都在吵架。我确信我儿子感觉到了，确信他会因此记恨我，确信我错了，但确信我当时是对的。
At the first sign of daybreak, I got out of bed and went down to the beach. I walked south along the entire length of the shore before turning around and heading back. As I grew closer to the beach across from our villa, I saw something dark and heavy in the shallow water. I thought it was a log or a mass of seaweed, but then I saw it was moving. It was kicking. It was a person. And as I grew closer still, I realized it was Marvin. It was Marvin, and he was struggling to get to shore.
黎明的第一缕曙光，我起床走到海滩。我沿着整个海岸线向南走，然后转身走回来。当我走近我们别墅对面的海滩时，我看到浅水中有一些深色且重的东西。我以为那是圆木或一团海藻，但我看到它在移动。它在踢水。是个人。当我更靠近时，我意识到是马文。是马文，他正挣扎着想上岸。
I hate to admit it, but even as I ran to help him, I was pissed off. It was bad enough I had to put up with this pain in the ass. Now I had to save him? I grabbed Marvin around his chest, lifting and pulling as I swung his arm across my shoulder. He was coughing spluttering, trying to catch his breath. I'm all right, he was saying, I'm all right.
我讨厌承认这一点，但即使当我跑去帮他时，我也火大。我已经忍受这个累赘够久了。现在我还要救他？我搂住马文的胸口，把他举起来拖向岸边，把他的胳膊架在我的肩上。他咳嗽着，气喘吁吁。“我没事，”他说，“我没事。”
I helped him onto the beach. I was breathing heavily. That, I said, was the most pathetic cry for attention I have ever seen. Marvin laughed and took a moment to catch his breath. My wife, he said. Yeah, I said. Auschwitz. He shook his head. Second wife, he said. We came here together for 25 years. We used to get up for early morning swims. As I got older, it got harder for me to get back to the shore, undertow and all. She would stand at the edge and wait for me to come back. She sounds great, I said. She was, said Marvin. I shook my head. Such a shame she wasted all those years with you. Marvin laughed again. We have the same sense of humor, he said. We should spend more time together. I stood up, wiped the sand from my legs and hands, and uttered the most honest thing I'd said to Marvin since I met him. That sounds awful.
我把他扶上沙滩。我呼吸沉重。“那，”我说，“是我见过最可怜的求关注方式。”马文笑了笑，花点时间喘口气。“我妻子，”他说。“是啊，”我说。“奥斯威辛。”他摇摇头。“第二个妻子，”他说。“我们在这里一起度过了25年。我们过去常早起游泳。随着我年龄增长，我回到岸上变得更困难了，暗流什么的。她会站在边缘等我回来。”“她听起来很棒，”我说。“她确实很棒，”马文说。我摇摇头。“真是可惜她和你浪费了那么多年。”马文又笑了。“我们有相同的幽默感，”他说。“我们应该多在一起待待。”我站起来，抹掉腿和手上的沙子，说出了我见到马文以来对他说的最诚实的话。“那听起来太糟糕了。”
Marvin smiled and we walked back to our rooms. And after that moment, he never bothered me again. I'd wasted three days trying to be polite to someone I couldn't stand and nearly ruined another vacation. But by finally being the ass I really am, I'd saved it.
马文微笑着，我们走回房间。从那一刻起，他再也没有打扰过我。我浪费了三天试图对一个我无法忍受的人表现礼貌，并差点毁了另一个假期。但通过终于成为那个真实的我，我拯救了它。
I was cordial enough. Marvin waved when I saw him in the TV room, telling Holocaust stories to the young couple who checked in that evening. And I waved back. He nodded when I saw him at breakfast the following morning, telling a pair of young waitresses about mass graves in Sobibor. And I nodded back.
我表现得足够有礼貌。我在电视室看到他时向马文挥手，他正给那天晚上入住的年轻夫妇讲大屠杀故事。我也挥手回应。第二天早晨吃早餐时看到他，他正在告诉那两个年轻女服务员关于索比堡的大规模墓地。我也点点头回应。
And then we finished our breakfast. And my wife took my hand in hers, and she smiled at me. And I smiled at her. And together we walked, arm in arm, to watch the sun, still rising, over the unspoiled beach below.
然后我们吃完早餐。我妻子牵起我的手，向我微笑。我也对她微笑。我们挽着手一起走，去看太阳在下方的原始海滩上冉冉升起。
Shalom Auslander is the author, most recently, of the memoir, Foreskin's Lament, which is out in hardback, and comes out in paperback October 4.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德是回忆录《包皮的挽歌》的作者，该书近期出版，平装本将于10月4日面市。
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and P.J. Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好吧，我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维兹经营我们的网站。制作帮助来自赛斯·林德和P.J.沃格特。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who joins me here in the studio today. Torey, get a little closer to the microphone, OK? Are you feeling OK?
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他今天和我一起在录音室里。托里，靠近麦克风一点，好吗？你感觉还好吗？
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。